salut à tous Bienvenue chez envergure
c'est notre podcast Victor et l'ISO
épisode du mois de mai on parle de
Victor web benyama donc de son talent au
tir précisément dans cet épisode et puis
de ces futurs possibles équipe NBA Hugo
il prenne la Victor se fils dans le
destin d'effraya les gazettes au menu
première partie on va plonger dans la
technique de tiers de Victor one bagnat
précisément qu'est-ce qui fait qui est
si bon qu'il est projeté sillo on entre
vraiment dans le détail physique
technique avec Guillaume visade le coach
de Vichy Clermont Pro B et puis deuxième
partie à quelques jours de la loterie de
la draft tu aimes bien quelles équipes
donnera le meilleur environnement à
Victor comment il faut l'accompagner
c'est le retour d'Alan dans le podcast
on y va
la première partie on va donc parler du
tir de Victor weembanyama et pour ça on
a invité Guillaume visade coach de Vichy
Clermont merci d'être avec nous
Guillaume merci de l'invitation
avec toi je voulais qu'on parle qu'on
parle du tir de Victor parce que on
n'arrête pas de dire que c'est un joueur
exceptionnel mais on aime bien rentrer
dans le détail ici envergure et je
voulais savoir avant qu'on parle de son
shoot à lui qu'est-ce que toi en tant
que en tant que coach en tant que
formateur aussi tu observes quand tu
regardes le tir d'un joueur en fait
c'est quoi qui qui vers quoi ton œil va
déjà le tir d'un joueur il est unique
c'est-à-dire que ces angles de tir entre
sa cheville c'est genou ses hanches en
poignet la manière dont il attrape la
balle la manière dont il finit son geste
tout ça quand on l'additionne ça donne
souvent une formule unique et puis en
plus c'est une formule qui est souvent
variable suivant les situations et qui
se reproduit pas donc on essaye de voir
un petit peu les tendances de les
tendances de tir d'un joueur de voir
s'il tire en un temps si ils tirant deux
temps
si de manière plus efficace sur les
réceptions tir si réussi à tirer après
des dribbles s'il réussit à tirer après
des déplacements etc etc donc tout ça
cumulé puis ensuite les situations dans
lesquelles ils tirent quand on
contextualise aussi avec les moments
dans la possession les moments dans le
match moi ça nous donne petit à petit un
bon étalonnage de
qui est ce joueur en tant que shooter et
alors
justement quel tendance qu'est-ce que tu
trouves déjà remarquable chez Victor one
bagnama quand tu le regardes shooter et
après on ira sur les tendances dont tu
donc tu as évoqué à l'instant
la première chose c'est la notion de
fluidité et elle est d'autant plus
remarquable qu'elle est très difficile à
atteindre chez un joueur de sa taille et
en plus de sa taille d'un joueur qui a
ses levier que ce soit
au niveau de la taille de ces jambes la
hauteur de séance ou de son envergure et
réussir à obtenir une fluidité
avec ses caractéristiques avoir un tir
en un seul mouvement sans saccade sans
séquence déjà ça c'est c'est
exceptionnel
et quand ajouter à ça on ajoute la
manière dont il récupère le ballon pour
pouvoir le monter et ensuite enchaîner
son tir ça donne deux critères
exceptionnels qu'on retrouve que très
rarement et que chez des joueurs avec
des potentialités de très très haut
niveau c'est à dire la manière de
récupérer le ballon
en fait la manière dont il prend la
balle au niveau de séance qu'il
enclenche son tir et ses poignets et qui
passe on va dire
qui passe sous le ballon avec avec sa
main et que tu vois ce mouvement
d'épaule où tu passes sous la balle pour
ensuite enchaîner ton tir ça c'est c'est
remarquable parce que il réussit à le
faire dans les trois contextes dans le
tir de spot dans le tir après dribble et
dans le tir après déplacement et ça
c'est remarquable parce que très souvent
les gens qui ont une très grande
envergure et qui sont grands ils ont ils
sont obligés de s'organiser différemment
on va prendre l'exemple du de peut-être
l'un des meilleurs shooters du monde
Kevin Durant mais lui pour justement
peut-être gérer les forces de ces
leviers ben il a il récupère le ballon
très souvent un petit peu de manière
désaxée sur le sur le côté de sa hanche
pour ensuite le ramener à hauteur et et
très certainement que ça facilité son
schéma moteur pour développer son tir et
que il a une habitude de très haut
niveau là dessus
Victor le fait que lui il est construit
une manière de récupérer son ballon ben
on va dire qui est plus proche d'un
des postes de shooter de ce que font
historiquement on va dire ou peut-être
de manière observable et bien je trouve
que ça c'est exceptionnel voilà et ça ça
va lui permettre de d'accéder à des à
des tirs qui qui sont pas normalement
accessibles à des typologies de tirs
dont tu parlais tout à l'heure qui sont
pas normalement accessibles à des à des
gens de cette taille
c'est surtout que c'est une compétence
qui est qui reste ouverte c'est à dire
que dans n'importe quelle situation de
jeu il peut réussir à retrouver
son geste après la notion d'efficacité
on peut on peut la questionner on pourra
revenir dessus mais surtout qu'ils se
retourne par exemple sur un fait de
ouais qui qui soit sur un dribble tir
qui soit sur un tir après un crossover
ben dans toutes ces situations là mais
lui en fait il a et on va dire qu'il a
une compétence ouverte sur le tir c'est
à dire que peu importe le contexte il va
réussir à retrouver la position de ses
mains la rotation de son ballon son
équilibre et ça c'est très riche sur le
plan moteur sur le plan des patterns de
tout ce qu'il a développé dans dans ses
acquisitions motrices c'est très riche
est-ce qu'il y a d'autres tendances
quand tu disais au début que tu
observais le shoot d'un joueur qu'est-ce
que tu as observé d'autre qui par
rapport à ses préférences peut-être de
dire
c'est la manière dont il réussit à se
fléchir et à faire varier
faire varier la hauteur de son dribble
et où quand il se redresse et là aussi
va retrouver son équilibre quand on peut
regarder ses épaules par exemple quand
il est en train de dribbler et ses
épaules elles vont se fléchir vers
l'avant et il va être sur une situation
où il est en train d'attaquer en dribble
et dans n'importe quel dribble il peut
réussir à retrouver son équilibre pour
tirer
et ça aussi c'est une caractéristique on
retrouve beaucoup plus chez des joueurs
on va dire classique extérieur et on
peut comprendre que lui possédant cette
qualité
c'est aussi lié à sa mentalité de pas
vouloir être mis dans une boîte et un
joueur limité et je pense que le fait
que cette année soit en pleine confiance
avec une capacité à prendre des tirs
variés dans des situations variées c'est
ce qui lui permet de montrer l'étendue
de son talent
pour toi
quand je t'écoute il y a pas l'air
d'avoir beaucoup de freins moteurs ou
gestuelle à
n'importe quel type de tir et est-ce que
est-ce que je me trompe est-ce que c'est
vraiment quelqu'un qui va être capable
de prendre tous les types de tirs à tous
les niveaux ou quasiment tous ou est-ce
que tu vois justement des choses qui
pourraient encore améliorer
il y aura toujours des choses qui peut
améliorer et puis ça ça sa capacité de
de travail sa volonté d'aller dans les
détails je pense qu'elle va l'aider à
progresser sur le sur le long terme
aujourd'hui c'est très difficile de se
dire qu'on peut l'empêcher de shooter
dans plusieurs situations du jeu
c'est assez difficile et d'ailleurs
quand on regarde un petit peu en détail
les les statistiques on se rend compte
que il marque déjà énormément de tirs
dans des situations compliquées c'est à
dire des tirs qui sont contestés des
tirs après dribble des tirs après des
collaborations défensives on a déjà
énormément de ces tir à lui qui sont
pris dans des conditions
finalement dans les conditions les plus
dures du basket donc c'est pour ça que
je pense qu'il faut peut-être
relativiser un petit peu le certains des
pourcentages c'est ce que j'allais dire
voilà ou en tout cas les comparer avec
ce type de tir c'est-à-dire que tu vois
sur le sur le nombre de paniers qui met
et par exemple 7 de ces paniers et bien
c'est des tirs contestés c'est à dire
que c'est des tirs où il y a quelqu'un
avec lui il y a quelqu'un ou des fois
deux joueurs qui ont la volonté de
l'empêcher de tirer et finalement malgré
ses conditions-là c'est à dire qu'il est
attendu on a on voudrait l'empêcher de
tirer ou le rendre dans des conditions
où on va complètement l'empêcher de
marquer et finalement il met quand même
dans ces conditions là dans le en
première division cette panier par match
dans ces conditions
comment du coup tu juges les variations
quand même statistiques puisqu'en début
d'année justement il marque beaucoup
avec un il marque beaucoup il a un
meilleur pourcentage pourcentage qui a
glissé
en cours de saison surtout le
pourcentage à trois points est-ce que
c'est vraiment dû uniquement à
l'adaptation des défenses ou est-ce que
je l'entendais aussi dire dans une
interview je travaille tellement mon
physique que j'ai pas trop le temps de
bosser mon shoot pour l'instant est-ce
que comment tu vois ça toi
ouais c'est je pense que c'est pas ça
peut pas être linéaire des deux côtés
c'est-à-dire qu'on peut pas progresser
de manière linéaire sur le plan physique
et en même temps progresser de manière
linéaire sur le plan du tir comme
toujours il va rencontrer des paliers
dans son dans son évolution et
mais quand on regarde une saison
complète bon les chiffres il donne il
donne déjà un bon aperçu
ce qui est intéressant c'est de voir que
malgré les fluctuations peut-être du
pourcentage à trois points le
pourcentage au lancer franc lui il reste
très solide pour un jeune joueur et dans
dans son poste de jeu surtout vu le
volume le volume de tir prix
et que
il y a aussi ce phénomène au début de
saison peut-être que les équipes se
disaient ben on va le défendre dans ce
dans le périmètre et puis après quand il
va sortir de la zone bah on va on va
peut-être juste contester s'étire on va
peut-être accepter qu'il joue sur des
piquets pop etc et quand il a commencé à
vraiment dominer des matchs avec trois
quatre tir à 3 points marqués dans ces
conditions là les équipes elles sont mis
à oeuvrer de manière différente soit en
switchant les piqu'n roll avec lui soit
en prenant le parti de de rester avec
lui quoi qu'il arrive et donc de lui
laisser moins de moins de liberté il y a
plusieurs exemples par exemple quand
Monaco quand ils sont venus voilà ils
sont ils sont
relayer sur lui en ayant des défenseurs
différents mais on voyait très bien que
la consigne c'était d'être au contact
permanent donc pour pouvoir se libérer
et tirer dans ces conditions
et réussir tout de même à être quasiment
à 33% à 3 points sur la sur la saison je
pense que c'est déjà c'est déjà
remarquable comment tu le défendrais toi
si ton équipe l'affrontait demain
[Musique]
c'est une question c'est une question
assez
compliqué
je pense que tout le monde se se casse
la tête sur ce
là-dessus
mais en tout cas on peut pas lui laisser
des tirs non contestés et ça c'est la
preuve que son niveau de tir est déjà
très important puisque les joueurs qu'on
veut à qui on veut pas laisser de catch
and shout c'est toujours les tops
joueurs et notamment des tops joueurs
dans le tir et donc si sur lui
stratégiquement on se dit ben quand il y
a des écrans avec lui on veut pas le
laisser libre peut-être soit on va
switcher soit on va se tiquer pour
rester collé à lui quand il veut aller
au large
quitte à laisser des libertés à d'autres
joueurs
si on est dans cette configuration là si
on fait ces choix techniques c'est que
vraiment on se dit que son tir peut
avoir une répercussion sur le gain ou
non du match
donc il est défendu comme un shooter et
je pense que depuis les 10 12 premiers
matchs du championnat depuis il est
défendu de cette manière là
avec une volonté très active de lui
laisser aucun cas Chan shoot par toutes
les équipes et il disait bien d'ailleurs
que
quand il parlait là dans son interview
récente avec la firstim il parlait de
l'expérience du match de face à l'équipe
de jillig et il disait qu'une des
grosses différences c'était c'était la
défense adverse pas tant le niveau des
défenseurs que les espaces que les
règles permettaient d'avoir du côté des
États-Unis quoi et que
viennent de plus loin
tellement loin qu'elles ne viennent pas
et donc
les schémas de jeu permettent de libérer
des espaces un petit peu plus grands ou
en tout cas les rotations web défensives
mais sont plus prévisible on a plus le
temps de les lire ou de les anticiper
les réseaux défensifs en France ou dans
les fenêtres internationales sont un peu
plus denses comment on optimise ça c'est
une grande question comment on optimise
le talent de Victor Wayne bagnat on se
rend compte quand on regarde un peu les
équipes vers vers lesquels il peut être
projeté que l'idéal ça c'est pas tant
les gens qui à côté de lui que peut-être
le
les schémas qu'on va lui donner la
créativité que le coach va avoir pour
toi qu'est-ce que et justement en
restant sur le tir comment quel tir on
essaye de lui donner quand on est un
coach et qu'on veut qu'on veut réussir
la particularité de victoire je pense
c'est un playmaker c'est quelqu'un qui
crée du jeu et qui initie des attaques
et donc forcément il faut qu'il soit au
centre du projet de jeu
[Musique]
en NBA on observe souvent l'usage de
l'usage du ballon pour qui initie les
attaques et quand on regarde cette
statistique
autour de Boulogne Levallois bon on se
rend compte que il est à plus de 30%
d'usage et ça c'est c'est une
caractéristique qui est symptomatique de
d'un joueur playmaker central dans une
attaque donc je sais
vu sa position à la draft et le type
d'équipe qui qui peut être vont le
récupérer très certainement que il va y
avoir une orientation forte du jeu
autour de lui avec des caractéristiques
différentes ce que ce que fait Denver
avec Joe kitsch a permis son
développement et son épanouissement pour
devenir un joueur total et je pense que
Victor il est il est un petit peu dans
hypolarise aussi beaucoup l'attention
mais son attention si elle est si elle
est bien utilisée elle servira aux
autres et elle donnera des espaces il y
a beaucoup des coéquipiers de jokis par
exemple qui qui font des statistiques
bien meilleur que que quand ils étaient
dans d'autres franchises et je pense que
victoire il a un petit peu ce potentiel
là et que peut-être qu'une des une des
choses où il va de il va devenir
excellent petit à petit c'est peut-être
son talent à la passe qui qui je pense
que dans les dans nos réseaux défensifs
il est moins invisible alors que je
pense que là aussi il a il a un plafond
assez haut dans sa créativité par la
passe et du coup est-ce que c'est un
playmaker face au jeu ou est-ce que
c'est parce que yokai il a la
particularité d'être un playmaker
souvent dos au panier du fait de sa
taille on le fait souvent des débuter
les possessions un peu d'eau au panier
ou en tout cas trois quarts d'eau quoi
des joueurs différents
je pense que le
sans positionnement il est il est plus
moderne à Victor encore c'est à dire que
il est vraiment face au cerf au large et
on peut l'imaginer dans l'axe on peut
l'imaginer dans l'aile pour initier du
jeu
tout en étant aussi et c'est là où
peut-être que la combinaison est un peu
différente c'est que il a aussi une
dimension du jeu qu'on appelle un peu
une troisième dimension dans l'espace
aérien par son volume de bras et sa
capacité à finir au dessus des défenses
ce qui fait que il peut aussi amener
cette polyvalence et peut-être qu'on on
a du mal aussi à voir que son niveau de
finition proche du cercle elle est aussi
élite
il a un pourcentage à deux points qui
est qu'à 47 48%, mais parce que il
souvent contre des prises à deux dans
cette situation là par contre quand il
est dans l'espace aérien quand il est
sur des rebonds offensifs quand il est
dans ces situations voilà
par exemple surtout les dents qu'il a
cette année il est à deux points par
possession c'est à dire que il rate pas
dans cette situation là surtout les
situations de lay up quand il est dans
dans des duels ou avec un petit avantage
il est un point 7 par possession et donc
ça c'est des statistiques si les
reportent en MBA il fera partie des tous
meilleurs finisseurs de la Ligue c'est
des statistiques qui sont proches de
Clean capella etc absolument ça c'est
des choses que tu regardes quand tu
regardes les stats avancés
qu'est-ce qui qu'est-ce qui t'attire
l’œil dans son profil statistique
justement
et sur ces stats là avancer auquel toi
tu as accès
après
ça ça attire l'oeil parce qu'on voit la
double compétence la compétence du tir
et des tirs complexes dans les
isolations dans les fins de possession
dans les tirs à pré dribbles et en même
temps
une efficacité déjà affirmée dans les
dans les finitions proches du cercle
notamment dans certaines situations de
de pick and roll
et après on essaie de regarder aussi un
petit peu les points qui sont que que
lui il marque qui sont générés par des
passes de ces coéquipiers donc ils
viennent du jeu et lui Ben sur ces
sur sa moyenne de points il y a
finalement il y a que 4,6 points qui
sont générés par des passes de ces
coéquipiers
un avantage
et ensuite c'est les points que lui crée
grâce à ses postes d'écran qui génèrent
et peut-être que là dessus au niveau
supérieur s'il a un s'il a un playmaker
à côté de lui en arrière scorer par
exemple que ce chiffre là va encore
augmenter actuellement il est à 2,5 je
pense que ça c'est un chiffre qui peut
qui peut nettement s'améliorer aussi
ouais nécessairement le nombre de points
générés par les autres qui marquent lui
va pourrait augmenter vu le personnel
qui pourrait avoir ça dépend où il tombe
évidemment mais mais il y a quand même
des souvent des joueurs qui sont qui
sont créateurs plusieurs en tout cas par
équipe
NBA
est-ce qu'il y a quelque chose dont on
n'a pas parlé autour du tir puisque je
crois que je suis arrivé au bout de mes
interrogations à moi mais peut-être que
tu as d'autres choses à dire sur sur le
tir de Victor qu'on aurait qu'on aurait
pas dit
après on peut regarder la trajectoire
c'est que lui il a aussi
développer et créer sa propre
trajectoire c'est à dire que son ballon
il est il est libéré à une hauteur avec
une trajectoire qui est quand même bien
prononcé vers le cercle
et donc ça c'est aussi quelque chose qui
est qu'on peut qu'on peut observer
et qui est qui est aussi assez assez
remarquable puisque là aussi je trouve
qu'il y a de la régularité dans sa
trajectoire je parle de l'angle de
l'angle du lâcher de ballon et de langue
d'arrivée dans le cercle en fait
et le chemin que le ballon que le ballon
que le ballon parcours et
ça
dans la recherche de spacing en NBA ou
on se dit ben de toute manière il faut
qu'on écarte le jeu etc bon bah là vous
avez un joueur de très grande taille qui
en plus a lâché du ballon qui est très
haut et donc ce qui lui permet de dire
s'il y a une rotation défensive par
exemple
c'est vous pouvez pas l'empêcher de
tirer
donc dans certaines situations ben ça va
étirer les défenses et ça va être une
même cantine tire pas sa seule position
sur le terrain va donner des espaces et
va écarter les aides défensives
quand tu quand tu parles de ta de la
trajectoire du ballon
quel avantage ça aurait par rapport à
une autre trajectoire en fait ce que tu
disais tout à l'heure les shoots sont
uniques tu veux dire c'est plus sur le
point de départ ou le fait que la
trajectoire soit assez bombée pour que
ce soit encore plus difficilement
contrable que s'il avait un shoot un peu
plat le point de départ et puis ensuite
les ondulations pour rentrer dans le
cercle parce que
ça ça permet d'avoir un d'avoir un le
fait d'avoir déjà une qualité de
trajectoire là aussi on peut imaginer
que petit à petit le joueur devienne
vraiment expert dans le fait de marquer
des tirs les spécialistes du tir très
souvent ils disent ben les le shooter
quand il évolue il passe d'un shooter
qui vise le fond de cercle un shooter
qui vise le devant du cercle et que son
objectif c'est de faire rentrer le
ballon sans toucher
ça c'est beaucoup de shooter de de
player development des gens qui
travaillent spécifiquement sur le tir
ils ont cette observation et je pense
que voilà le travail de Victor son
travail d'oeil la manière dont il
accroche le cercle et la hauteur à
laquelle il lâche le ballon et commence
à rentrer et bien je pense que ça lui
donne une potentialité de haut niveau là
dessus
et bien merci beaucoup Guillaume d'avoir
sorti ton expertise bon courage Bonne
chance pour la fin de saison avec Vichy
Clermont
donc c'était pour pour ceux qui ne te
connaissent pas coach donc de
Vichy Clermont en Pro B qui espère
espère encore les playoffs si je dis pas
de bêtises on a encore deux hypothèses
on va dire si on gagne un des deux
derniers matchs ou les deux derniers
matchs bon on est sûr à 100% de d'y
parvenir et puis si jamais les résultats
des autres nous étaient favorables on
pourrait garder notre position aussi
mais je pense qu'il vaut mieux compter
que sur nous et ce soir un gros match
contre Chalon Reims à domicile
ce vendredi 5 mai où tu joues face à
Chalon Reims qui est une des une des
tops équipe aussi de championnat de Pro
BM merci beaucoup Guillaume d'avoir été
avec nous d'envergure et à bientôt à
bientôt au revoir
c'est la deuxième partie quel est donc
la franchise idéale de Victor ou plutôt
vu que ici on est plus dans l'analyse
que dans le débat de comptoir quel est
son environnement idéal et on va essayer
de voir si ça correspond à certaines
franchises qui pourraient tomber sur lui
grâce à la loterie qui a donc lieu dans
quelques jours on enregistre le samedi
13 mai et on parle de ça avec notre
Wonder kids Alan Guillot ça va Alan
salut Alex salut à tous ouais bah ouais
tu m'as revenir gentiment pour pour
enregistrer donc j'ai demandé
autorisation à bpost et avec plaisir
donc c'est super plaisir d'être là pour
ceux qui te connaissent pas ex membre à
plein temps du podcast et désormais
grade assistante pour la fac de Santa
Clara
toujours un oeil sur Victor quand même
vu qu'on va parler de lui bien sûr
je regarde j'essaie de regarder un peu
quelques matchs
je pense dans l'année pas plus je vais
pas mentir mais c'est un peu ça c'est un
peu la folie mais c'est la folie en
France j'ai l'impression mais c'est la
folie Victor elle est aussi ici depuis
les deux matchs de Las Vegas
ça c'est par tomber quoi ah non c'est
pas retombé parce que tu allais la NBA
qui partage de Victor au quotidien qui
commente les matchs qui les stream donc
la loterie arrive très bientôt donc non
non non c'est
il y a le show sur ispn qui a été sorti
récemment aussi donc la folie est
complète donc là loterie donc
probablement l'équipe qui sera numéro 1
choisira Victor sauf tremblement de
terre et autres invasions
extraterrestres les pourcentages donc
qui ont été changés il y a quelques
années
D3
Houston San Tonio ont 14% de chance de
voir le premier choix de la draft
Charlotte 12 et demi Portland 10 et demi
Orlando 9 Indiana 6.8 Washington 6.7 et
ensuite on descend dans des gens qui
aurait vraiment beaucoup de chance Yuta
Dallas 4h30 3% Chicago
Oklahoma Toronto New Orleans tout ça
c'est à moins de 2%
d'obtenir le firstick évidemment vous
avez le tableau sur le site de tankaton
avec avec tous les pourcentages de
chance
[Musique]
on va pas parler des équipes
immédiatement mais pour toi
Alan que comment quel environnement tu
imagines autour de Victor et on parle
vraiment de l'année prochaine
c'est-à-dire d'un moment où il sera
peut-être pas très probablement pas
encore une superstar en NBA
[Musique]
surpiquen roll c'est-à-dire en
transition c'est à dire quelqu'un qui
fait vraiment des bons choix autour de
lui qui on n'est pas vraiment Victor qui
doit forcer par moment ou qui se
retrouvent parfois peu servi et il faut
pour moi un autre intérieur pour que
Victor puisse peut-être débuter en tant
que rumeur donc en tant que rôle un peu
à la Robert Williams elle avait pas de
moblet et donc là qui est un peu plus
costaud clip peut-être plus centre de
gravité plus bas qui absorbe le contact
de certains intérieurs et puis Victor
qui entoure de contrôle à côté ça sera
peut-être deux choses c'est un peu
cliché parce qu'on peut mettre les deux
choses que je mettrai en avant un peu
copié bah tu parles d'événements blé lui
effectivement défensivement en tout cas
il est mis dans de bonnes conditions par
Cleveland quoi c'est à dire que il a
déjà arrêté Allen qui qui va prendre les
gros babares à côté quoi ou jaren
Jackson avec bah pas launchuna c'est
plus style Adams absolument et qui après
en play effectivement va passer du temps
en position de Center exactement mais
c'est vrai que pour la saison régulière
la saison est longue
et quand tu parles de offensivement
tu parles de plus c'est la balle en
transition etc on parlait avec Guillaume
visa en première partie il le voit quand
même avoir la balle face au Cercle
offensivement Victor
est-ce que ça veut dire aussi que le
grand dont on parle ça doit être aussi
un bon poseur d'écran quoi ou ou qui est
des gardes qui soient des bons poseurs
d'écran aussi puisque c'est pic and roll
Inversé sont à la mode oui clairement
l'inversé ou ce qu'ils appellent ici
widget de screen
rejet de l'écran et donc pour après par
exemple avoir Victor face aux serres
pour un flotteur ou pour un médisance ou
pour un jeu de face up parce que attends
parler avec Guillaume mais le toucher
qu'il a à sa taille des équipes vont en
profiter en fait donc ça va être
clairement là dessus
je pense que oui il faut un bon poseur
d'écran après c'est toujours le dilemme
il faut toujours je pense quatre
shooters sur le terrain Victor sera le
shooter sera un des quatre shooters donc
tu peux te permettre
un peu de
le mettre avec un joueur qui est
peut-être strictement dans le rebond
offensif
les écrans et le rôle parce que
ton spécing n'en sera pas totalement
détruit là où Evan meublé mais qui prend
pas encore énormément de trois points
qui n'aurait pas trop on a vu
apparemment en playoff que le spacing
était un peu problématique en plus parce
que bon là il y a genre mais je pense
que Victor de par son arsenal offensif
et du fait que le tir va se transposer
t'offre vraiment la possibilité de le
mettre avec un joueur qui va vraiment
être proche du cercle et donc dans les
écrans dans l'air bon offensif dans la
défense du poste donc là dessus je pense
qu'il y a vraiment polyvalence qui va
qui peut vraiment être super intéressant
ouais un peu dans le sale boulot aussi
et pour le coach alors ça c'est des
trucs qui peuvent encore plus changer à
l'intérieur mais
quel dans quel genre de système un peu
offensif donc tu as dit défensivement un
peu rumeurs mais
est-ce qu'il faut un coach qui l'utilise
un peu comme Vincent Collet
qui a mis de côté un peu son son côté un
peu strict pour parfois laisser libre
cours à la créativité de Victor et ce
qu'il faut plutôt le l'orienter sur
certaines sur certains systèmes en début
comment tu vois la situation du coach
par rapport à Victor
on va dire que la saison régulière pour
regarder pas mal de NBA on est plus sur
des couvertures pas complexes il y a
très peu de vraiment de matchup à tes
équipes qui sont spécialisées en switch
total mais le plus on va dire que ce
qu'on voit le plus c'est du drop donc tu
dors pas très
compliqué il y a un peu de Edge
apparemment donc c'est à dire
l'intérieur qui va sortir sur le
pick-ning roll venir toucher le porteur
de balle et ensuite
retourner proche du panier je pense que
ça Victor peut le faire
je pense que vu que c'est l'un des
peut-être un des meilleurs rimes
protecteurs qu'on a vu
depuis
très longtemps il a la possibilité il a
fait des épisodes sur sa mobilité fine
sur le fait qu'il puisse dans les petits
espaces à motricité celui qui puisse
contrer avec les deux mains je pense que
ça va être un très très bon joueur un
très très bon protecteur de cercle sur
drop honnêtement je pense que là-dessus
tu peux en faisant régulière faire ça
après la question sera en playoff
comment ça va se passer parce que on a
vu en parlant cette année en bethlé
Kelly on l'a vu un peu sur le match à
Vegas c'est pas et c'est normal parce
qu'il est à 75 seven five et quasiment
il a 8 d'envergure je sais plus combien
ça fait
normal qu'il fasse faire global par les
des gardes en fait donc
faudra faudra voir mais je pense que et
offensivement pardon pour le coach la
défense pour les systèmes tu vois ce que
tu le vois courir autour d'écran est-ce
que tu le vois jouer à glisso ce que tu
le vois jouer dans un jeu plus en
mouvement ou justement plus arrêter je
dois jouer je le vois poper sur dupick
and pop je pense
je le vois comme tu l'avais dit encore
peut-être un peu un jeu de face up à
l'elbo c'est à dire on va lui donner la
balle et puis on va lui laisser un peu
un bout de terrain pour pour jouer ISO
et puis c'est un tel chocmaker que il
pourra faire ça et puis on avait vu on a
vu un peu en transition moi je trouvais
que il court pas il court bien
anormalement bien pour pour sa taille
donc je pense que avec un meneur créatif
après avoir beaucoup beaucoup de paniers
de panier facile après pour regarder un
peu ce qui se fait ce qui fait ce qui se
fait mettre cette année c'est un
packshotmaker
irréel pour sa taille quoi donc je pense
que
il y aura de l'ISO il y aura dupliquer
une roll faut peut-être un peu plus de
lui en tant que roller je sais pas
la créativité elle peut être
irréelle en fait donc vraiment c'est moi
j'ai hâte de voir j'ai hâte de voir les
premiers les premiers mois en tout cas
les trois équipes qu'on les meilleurs
chances c'est donc des trois Houston San
Antonio
est-ce qu'il y en a une des trois dans
ta tête qui qui fit le profil que tu as
décrit avec le garde créatif à la fois
en transition et en Mitterrand et
un coach pas trop pas trop arrêté sur
ces idées et
un intérieur un peu un peu solide qui
vient faire le sale boulot prendre les
coups que
Victor peut se permettre de ne pas
prendre vu qu'il a beaucoup de talons
en vrai il y en aurait il y en a pas
trop mais ça serait plus étroit
parce que il y a quelques dégâts alors
peut-être beaucoup de gens oublient
parce qu'il a pas trop il a quasiment
pas jouer cette année parce que c'était
première année NBA c'est un peu
complexes faut bien le dire mais en tant
que création sur pick & roll
c'est ça peut être vraiment de très haut
niveau et il y a déjà les durer
[Musique]
mais ça reste quand même très
utile et il y a déjà une durée alors ils
ont d'autres projets l'intérieur mais si
tu as possibilité d'avoir tes Yama ça va
devenir le projet central donc il y a
pas de coach par contre encore je crois
et voilà parce que c'est vrai que je
pense que alors offensivement peut-être
qu'une qu'une racine qu'une personne ou
Victor peut être vraiment ouais c'est
extrêmement exceptionnel mais
je sais pas si défensivement est sur le
garde play ça peut être je sais pas
faudrait vraiment des bons progrès de
Julen green là dessus c'est possible il
est condamné il va être en année 3 et
puis sansonner c'est possible très jaune
c'est un bonheur NBA oui dans la
facilitation pour les autres c'est pas
flashy mais dès que tu regardes les
Spurs pourquoi des gars comme comme
potole ou comme d'autres intérieurs ont
pu bien jouer avec les sports c'est
parce que très jeune c'était solide et
c'est vrai qu'une paire avec
Victor côté de un peu de combo for Ward
comme Soran keldon Johnson Facel moi
j'aurais regardé après j'ai envie de
regarder toutes les équipes mais
avec Victor un peu envie de regarder
je dirais quand même des trois mais sans
Antonio et pas
peut faire censé un peu moins flashy
mais ça peut être ça peut faire sens
bon il y a évidemment le fantasme
Portland pour tout ce qui est qui adore
Damian lillard
et porte en général mais
et puis à Charlotte Charlotte qui a pas
trop utilisé mais on a vu sur la fin de
saison commence à utiliser Mark Williams
est-ce que pour toi Mark Williams peut
être cet intérieur
que tu décrivais moi j'ai un peu des
doutes mais qu'est-ce que tu en penses
je préfère un peu Marc William dans le
rôle peut-être qu'on projette de Victor
à la Robert Williams Daniel garford Soro
là deuxième rideau deuxième lame mais
c'est vrai que je grouperai un peu
Charlotte et Indiana parce que la
ménopolitaine ça peut être
ça peut être du niveau de Garland pour
Eva de meublé en fait
l'implantation offensive en tout cas
vraiment ça peut vraiment
faciliter
l'implantation foncif de Victor et même
si on est tous très très haut sur Victor
et qu'on pense tous que c'est un
prospect générationnel ce qu'il est
il accueillera quand même besoin de bons
joueurs NBA au début avoir ces deux
jours là peuvent vraiment l'aider dans
les contextes après
en fait j'aurais bien un intérieur plus
vétérant en fait
c'est vrai que pour Janet Jackson avoir
Valentina puis
Adams c'est vraiment je trouvais un Game
changer dans son développement pour pour
NBA même margazole je crois tout tout au
début
Marc club c'est encore un même si
franchement il a montré des belles
choses c'est peut-être encore un peu
tendre
mais ça reste un profil d'intérieur
protecteur de cercle puissant puis là si
tu as les deux en termes de wingsman et
de protection de cercle tu oui
je suis un peu vétéran un peu vieux oui
il défend un peu moins bien mais au
poste il peut il peut défendre mais
c'est sûr que c'est pas déjà retalen
quoi non mais ça peut être le genre qui
prend le premier contact qui et qui se
bat sur les rebonds Victor changerait je
pense Victor les gens peut-être son
amour sur son stylo pensif et c'est vrai
mais c'est vrai que pour moi c'était
d'avoir un prospect défensif quand il
avait 16 et 17 ans
je pense qu'il change il a la
possibilité de changer ta défense juste
par sa présence on voit les équipes ont
peur de driver et donc là la sélection
de shoots de l'équipage adverse n'est
pas la même conseillé sur le terrain
donc même pour des défenses mauvaises
il a la capacité je pense vraiment de
changer la donne donc si pour Portland
ça peut ça peut aussi être le cas et
offensivement on parlait de avec
Guillaume du fait que
au niveau des contextes finalement il
peut un peu s'adapter à tout mais
il y a un truc qui est assez fou c'est
que c'est que tu vas ajouter de la
valeur à tes autres joueurs très
probablement en ajoutant Victor web
benyama ton effectif parce que
comme tous les très très bons joueurs et
bah les autres vont être meilleures
grâce à lui parce qu'il va porter de
l'espace parce que il va couvrir leurs
errements défensifs à qui dans ce lot
dont on a parlé à qui ça pourrait bien
bénéficier en termes de voilà de il y a
une équipe où il y a pas mal de joueurs
qui attendent juste un petit truc pour
franchir un palier et devenir vraiment
ultra solide quoi des steps bons
starters NBA
c'est vraiment une très bonne question
je pense que
[Musique]
je pense que la méloball honnêtement
à jamais eu vraiment un intérieur
il a eu plein le lit surtout le début de
sa carrière pas vraiment une de roller
de menaces de l'homme
et après on ouvrait pas mal attaque en
faisant Washington mais
tu le payes de l'autre côté du terrain
donc
je pense que lui peut être vraiment
celui qui bénéfique Plus bénéficie le
plus mais c'est déjà un genre établi il
a été all star on en pense qu'on veut il
a été il a été au star sa deuxième année
[Musique]
et si tu le grave ta Charlotte qu'est-ce
que tu fais depuis que Washington par
exemple
très bonne question
tu peux essayer de jouer les deux
ensemble effectivement
[Musique]
mais c'est vrai que tu as aussi le
projet Marc Williams comme tu l'as dit
ils ont d'autres projets intérieurs
comment il s'appelle
Kai Jones tout cela mais
c'est adapte après je pense que le
Victor aussi comme tu le disais comme la
première partie du métal sur mon avant
en fait il va t'offrir d'énormément de
possibilités parce qu'il va en fait il
va cacher beaucoup de choses si tu as
des extérieurs qui se défendent pas très
bien il va te permettre quand même de
pas de faire atomiser sur les drives
donc pour une équipe comme Portland en
faire les Symons notamment ça peut ça
peut ça peut aider une équipe comme
Houston
qui est une porteur challenge green
ces joueurs là ont vraiment bénéficier
parce que si tu as ta Victor côté de
tarison par exemple au côté de d'autres
joueurs comme ça qui doucement de Garou
bah je sais pas quel projet là-bas mais
tu peux vraiment avoir une belle assise
défensive derrière tes gardes juste que
les gardes soient suffisamment fort
offensivement pour qu'il puisse jouer
avec des joueurs qui sont moins bons
offensivement à l'intérieur mais tu peux
avoir cette dualité
il est peut-être il est dans la même il
est dans la même conversation que
l'amélo ball juste il a juste il a eu
mal Turner il a hurric Carla il est
vraiment un super bon contexte donc il a
déjà montré toutes ces choses là mais
ouais quelques green c'est un peu cliché
mais la mélo on fait un insimon
et puis voilà
exactement et puis ça peut permettre de
jouer avec plus de jours offensifs sur
les postes extérieurs parce que tu vas
pas non plus de faire torpiller
défensivement je pense et dernière
question très rapide c'est que c'est pas
ton sujet préféré les filles
psychologiques ouais
vu la personnalité qui exhibe Victor
cette année celle d'un leader pas trop
un leader gueulard mais un mec qui aime
bien quand même être le numéro 1 et qui
l'assume il comprend en équipe de France
et ce qu'il faut qu'il soit le leader de
l'équipe tout de suite est-ce que ça
peut poser des problèmes s'il ne l'est
pas
c'est une bonne question je te dirais
que mon avis il a changé maintenant que
je suis au contact de joueurs au
quotidien je pense qu'il y a
le leader par leader par l'ancienneté
mais il y a aussi le leader par
la l'exemple l'éthique de travail et
juste être le meilleur joueur sur le
terrain même si tu es pas le plus ancien
donc tu peux en avoir plusieurs quoi
exactement et puis on peut quand même
vraiment te suivre même si tu es nouveau
dans un dans un effectif on peut quand
même te suivre et être derrière toi en
tant que leader
juste parce que soir après soir tes
productif et que les gens voient que tu
es ceux qui ont des ceux qui travaillent
le plus donc ça va être c'est une bonne
question parce que Victor arrive dans un
contexte dans un autre pays des joueurs
qui sont alors tout le monde le connaît
tout le monde le connaît mais il y a
quand même toujours parfois ces petits
oh faudra qu'ils nous prouvent ici enfin
qui nous prouve en NBA les gens ne
connaissent pas vraiment le niveau de la
bête qui élite donc il y aura ça mais je
pense que ça peut être comme Luca en
fait je compare pas mais ça peut être
comme Luca ou comme d'autres profils
internationaux qui sont venus
et qui en fait ont tout de suite après
30-40 matchs ont montré que voilà on
pouvait vraiment les suivre dans Ça
c'est un peu ce que je projette pour
pour lui honnêtement OK
est-ce que tu as quelque chose à ajouter
est-ce qu'il y a une équipe en vrai qui
te ferait vraiment kiffer
au-delà de des choses qu'on a abordées
[Musique]
ça serait pour le projet du je pense que
le basket va sur ça moi des très grands
avec des skills de petits donc
je pense que ça peut être ça peut être
le futur en fait
Victor et je sais pas comment
je sais pas comment on joue mais
c'est clair une expérimentation le
laboratoire du futur exactement bon
merci Alan merci à toi c'était vraiment
cool et merci à vous tous de nous avoir
écoutés suivez les aventures d'Alan sur
son Instagram
Santa Clara ça joue bien en vrai donc
pour la prochaine saison n'hésitez pas à
aller voir et puis et puis nous on se
retrouve régulièrement désormais puisque
sa dernière ligne droite avant la draft
donc il y a tout plein de podcasts
il y a des scouting report sur le site
il y a également des des mini capsules
de 20 minutes pour des portraits de
chaque de chaque joueur de draft
l'essentiel sur sur chacun des groupes
prospects et puis le Big board la
mobdraft sur sur envergure.co également
allez ciao tout le monde